hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive and it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
the financial times as chief political
correspondent jim pickard and the
journalist and broadcaster leslie
riddick they're going to be with us from
now until just before midnight thank you
both very much for joining us so let's
see what's on the front of some of those
papers
and the guardian writes that the
architects of the paris agreement say
that the cop climate targets are too
weak
the metro reports on what it calls a 999
calls crisis with ambulances in england
taking on average three times longer
than their target to reach patients
while the northern echo says tens of
thousands of patients in its region
alone are waiting to be seen for
non-covert problems
the eye here is that the tory mp natalie
elfic who told marcus rashford to focus
on his day job when he was campaigning
for free school meals has herself been
holding down a second job which pays 36
000 pounds a year
the times leads with this story about
mps writing that 14 of them are using
the parliamentary expenses scheme to
rent out their homes
whilst they stay in london
the telegraph says the us is concerned
russia may attempt to invade ukraine in
a repeat of its annexation of crimea in
2014.
according to the financial times the
passage of china's first historical
resolution in 40 years which will likely
see president xi jinping stay in power
for at least seven more years
is a move which is drawing comparisons
to chairman mao
well jim pickard and leslie riddick both
join us tonight uh up in scotland you're
both up there covering cop26 so we thank
you for for not being out on the lash on
the last night of the conference uh and
instead staying inside to talk to us um
let's start with with the cop
developments though um you know the
guardian that says that the type that
the targets are too weak to avoid
disaster are we going to be able to keep
it at 1.5
which was the
the stated aim of this leslie what is
your feeling after covering this for two
weeks do you feel that that perhaps
hopes were too high at the moment
it's so hard to say something about this
now because there there's so i mean
there's one quote somebody's come up
with today which is that there's a
draining complexity to this meeting like
no other by gum is that true um there's
also now almost breakouts there's so
many subgroups that have been
pushing their agendas we know about the
america china deal today there was uh
boga which is denmark and costa rica
those are the kind of front runners the
guys who want to run faster
so it feels like the the idea of having
one push to get 1.5 absolutely protected
seems to have sort of gone and uh this
this array of sub
agreements seems to be what people are
hoping they might manage to push for and
all the while the difficulty is that the
developing world is not going to abide
by um restrictions on its emissions as
its economy tries to grow
if there isn't going to be the money on
the table from the developed world which
it's actually welched on as a deal for
practically 10 years
jim i mean you know some of the
countries don't even want references to
fossil fuels to be inside these
documents it it does seem that the
ability to get all of these people to
even agree on the wording for anything
that can possibly be announced tomorrow
seems
possibly a little optimistic
yeah and what the experts here talk
about is they talk about a less common
denominator deal whereby you get the 200
countries in the room you finally reach
a point where you can all agree but for
that to happen the language has to be
incredibly vague and people were
surprised that yes the original draft
that came out yesterday did have a
reference to trying to eliminate fossil
fuels eventually no one believes that
will make it to the final communique as
that comes out at the weekend at some
indeterminate point and the story in the
guardian talking about how an on track
to hit 1.5 is they've interviewed two of
the architects of the paris agreement
from six years ago but nothing that
either of these gentlemen is saying is
going to come as a surprise to anybody
uh here at cop26 boris johnson obviously
the host of cop26 has talked about
coal cash cars trees which were kind of
four sub sub
agreements almost not anything to do
with cop26 itself they were sort of
separate fields the overarching aim of
the agreement however was keep 1.5 alive
which is to keep permissions on that
track and no one here thinks that's
possible
and we as a planet is currently on track
for something more like 2.4 degrees of
heating and that may sound like quite a
narrow difference we are told by climate
experts that there is a world of
difference between those two and we are
definitely on the wrong track
leslie do you think there's any chance
that we might see the prime minister
coming back up
um i don't know
from from having been there what i heard
from quite a number of the uh the
observers who were actually
screened out mostly of the plenary
sessions and unable to get in as they
were to previous cop sessions and what
they felt was that um the leaders had
all come at the beginning primarily to
avoid being there holding the baby as it
were right at this moment when not very
much is achieved or at least 1.5 is not
safeguarded um so the thinking is that
probably leaders are not going to want
to be there at the end that happened in
copenhagen where they all turned up at
the end and actually there really wasn't
the result that they'd hoped for i don't
know if boris johnson arriving boosting
this boosterism idea i don't know that
this is really where we're stuck with
with
the the the detail now so i'd be
astonished myself if boris johnson came
back but you know um
he's he's seemingly quite fond of taking
the train these days
right the other big story of the week
aside from from cop has of course been
sleaze mps second jobs what mp should i
shouldn't be doing um jim you've done
you've done a piece which is on the
front of the ft um and perhaps it was
inevitable quite a thorough examination
of boris johnson's outside earnings what
have you revealed
so i mean this this whole scandal has
taken quite a strange twist which was
the original story which was so damaging
was this attempt by the prime minister
boris johnson to whip his own tory mps
into an attempt to overturn the entire
standard system basically to save the
neck of owen patterson this disgraced
former cabinet minister
boris johnson ended up resigning despite
boris johnson ended up u-turning which
led to owen patterson resigning but the
story is kind of like when you start a
fire in a prairie the fire is is now
spreading and the media returning there
or our attention to other mps with
second jobs and there's quite a lot of
unsavory stuff coming out there you all
know about geoffrey cox the barrister
who's been advising
a tax haven in the caribbean 4 000 miles
away when he was supposedly meant to be
representing his constituents in
parliament
now boris johnson popped up yesterday
and basically took the moral high ground
and said to his mps your primary duty
should be to your constituents i'd
expect you to be focusing most of your
attention on your day job but the only
problem with this as our ft research on
the front page says in tomorrow's paper
he himself has taken 4.3 million pounds
in outside earnings since only 2008 and
the only reason we can't calculate a
higher figure is that for the seven
years before that when he was mp
there weren't proper records kept by the
commons register of interest so
somewhere way north of four million
pounds he's taken on board to defend the
prime minister this wasn't through
consultancy or lobbying or some of the
things that have been particularly
controversial particularly in the owen
patterson case but even so it makes it
harder for him to preside over the
clear-up which he is claiming
to do i mean jim there's no suggestion
that he's that he's done this work since
becoming prime minister is there
no so the money the 4.3 million
basically divides into 2.7 million that
he did when he was the mayor of london
and most of that was from a con that he
did in the daily telegraph newspaper for
250 000 pounds a year which he at the
time described as chicken feed um
subsequently as he came back to the
house of commons in 2015 he did loads of
speeches he's been writing books
newspaper columns where he's picked up
another 1.6 million pounds and of course
when he was formed secretary he couldn't
do this kind of thing and his prime
minister he can do this kind of thing
although remember there was this rumor
that he's still trying to write a book
about william shakespeare and he's not
denied that he may be doing a bit of
work there on the side while prime
minister and also we make the point that
he's talking about and he should focus
on a single job but he himself was
editor of the spectator magazine in the
early 2000s for four years while being
an mp and he has also double headed the
job of mayor of london with being an mp
so it's really a story about boris
johnson trying to sort of set a good
example but his own track record is is
not necessarily quite as uh yeah easy to
defend this one
and le and leslie broadening it out now
if we look at the times their front page
story is is an another way that mps are
making money aside from the day job and
this is a rent expenses loophole where
where those based in london are are
renting out properties they already own
but rent to other people and then being
paid to live somewhere else
just explain it to you yes
well um jeffrey cox who seems to be the
gift that just keeps giving actually um
seems to be one of these who has a flat
uh it originally seems to have been paid
by the taxpayer um he however has
another flat which is the one that he
now claims money on and though
i think at one stage both of them have
been rented out as he trots the world um
working for companies located in
extremely exotic locations i mean
interestingly he was actually in
mauritius when he uh launched his um his
his uh defense of himself on his website
um with yet another um
legal firm that he he seems to be a
director of but i think him absolutely
it says jim says it is like this prairie
fire i wonder um despite the painstaking
work that jim's undertaken on boris
johnson if this will really damage him
particularly because
as everybody says
to be honest double standards and
getting away with it seems to be priced
into the boris offer it's the fact that
lesser uh mortals who perhaps have less
of what seems to be the kind of
well from north of the border is hard to
understand but charm or whatever it is
that boris johnson manages to exert to
get away with things and that doesn't
cover the this the ra realms of people
now that are being looked at and are
finding all sorts of bits of epoxy and
i'm old enough jim i don't think maybe
to remember all of this quite vividly
from the 1990s this is exactly how it
started last time around
it started and ended up with duck houses
didn't it um yeah yeah
it is just an ongoing story and um
staying with mps who possibly saying one
thing and doing another um jim the eyes
front page story its headline priceless
the mp who told rashford to focus on the
day job has a second job you couldn't
make it up could you
it's such a good headline there's almost
nothing left to say on
on top of that i don't think you even
need to know what the job is which is i
think it's chairing some kind of house
building industry group but it's just
it's just the most wonderful headline
going back to the times front page a
second ago i think the point of that
story was that not only jeffrey cox has
been proved that he's been uh taking
expenses for a flat in london while
renting out the property that he owns in
london i think the time does identify
a dozen other entities doing the same
thing and they include grande such as
liam foxx
a tory mp called philip davis and most
ironic of all in there is a guy called
john whittingdale who you'll remember as
a former culture minister who was going
to be lined up as the chair of this new
standards body which boris johnson was
trying to replace the existing perfectly
good standards body with a week ago it
was john whittingdale you broke up a
little bit there but thank you very much
both of you leslie let's start with you
for this section the daily telegraph and
all the papers in fact in this section
that we're looking at are looking at the
situation in belarus and what is
happening out there uh with russia
it's we've seen the airplanes coming
across belarus our correspondent there
reported on that yesterday but but now
the telegraph suggesting that this may
also be a way of russia bringing in
ukraine into this
yes i mean it seems like a really
alarming uh sort of escalation that's
happening here as you piece together did
the different stories that are uh
reporting on this you see these these
movements these mass movements of troops
now to that that border something like
90 000 troops apparently russian troops
that's what the ukrainians are reporting
and they've sent about eight and a half
thousand troops to meet them so clearly
that's never gonna hold but um it's it's
also interesting to see places like
estonia latvia lithuania all reporting
the same worries about buildups there's
reports that there's been meetings
between president biden and ursula
vonderlion whilst cops been going on
they've been meeting actually in the
white house in washington to to try to
discuss what to do next so there are all
the building blocks are beginning to be
there with of course the added possible
threat from belarus about gas supplies
and jim the guardian um
picks up on that very point that that
this is the next step isn't it that
belarus threatening to cut off the gas
are they behaving slightly childishly
this this is one of these situations
where you know obviously the russians
annexed crimea seven years ago and it
was made headlines for a few months and
then it kind of disappears off the radar
and the british public forget about it
but this is the situation which has been
grinding on ever since and there's
effects we've been a cold war or not not
a hot war really between
russian pro-russian dissidents in
eastern ukraine and kiev you know 14 000
people have lost their lives in that you
wouldn't know about that
you wouldn't believe that's happening
right on the edge of europe um and
russia's intentions towards ukraine are
obviously hostile the calculation putin
may eventually make or is probably
making regularly is whether or not this
time around nato will step in
jim and leslie i'm sorry to cut you off
but we are out of time for this half an
hour